SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, everybody.
And sorry to keep you waiting.
We were trying to
get all the sound
ready for a
beautiful performance
that we will se today.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'll be hosting the
king of ghazals.
Today it gives me great
pleasure to be here doing that.
And before I invite Mr.
Pankaj Udhas on stage,
I will say a few words about him
and give a brief introduction.
So as you all know, Padma
Shri award winner Pankaj Udhas
has been in the music industry
for more than three decades.
He started his journey with
ghazal singing in the '80s,
and produced many
amazing albums,
like "Aahat,"
"Mukarrar," "Tarrannum."
And then he made his
debut in the film industry
with a very iconic song
that we will talk about.
I'm sure it resonates a very
beautiful chord in our hearts
with that song that we
will share with you.
And he continues to do a
lot of work, even today.
He will be talking about
some of his recent projects.
He's also very involved
in a lot of non-profits
that he will talk about today.
So without further
ado, let me invite
Mr. Pankaj Udhas on stage.
Please give it up.
A warm round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
PANKAJ UDHAS: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER: All right, sir.
Please have a seat.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE] fans, [NON-ENGLISH]
Googlers, [NON-ENGLISH]..
I just wanted to give
you a very warm welcome.
[NON-ENGLISH]
PANKAJ UDHAS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So today, we
are the [NON-ENGLISH]..
Thank you very much.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Thanks so much.
SPEAKER: And as we were
talking over lunch,
you have come to the Bay
Area many, many times.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Oh, yes.
SPEAKER: But this is your
first time at Google.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Google, yes.
SPEAKER: So can you share a
little about your experience
over the years in Bay area,
and how is it different today?
PANKAJ UDHAS: Well, it's--
first of all, a very good
afternoon to everyone here.
And it's indeed a pleasure to be
here in this part of the world,
and especially at the
Google headquarters.
As I shared with
you this afternoon,
when I was talking
to the immigration
officer on my
arrival, he asked me
as to have I been to this
part of the world before?
And I told him that I
first came to United States
for a concert tour in 1986,
which makes it about 32 years.
So he looked at my face
and he says, are you sure?
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Like, that
was before I was born.
[LAUGHING]
PANKAJ UDHAS: And he
was a young gentlemen.
He couldn't believe
that I had been
coming to this wonderful
country for 32 years now.
Well, yes, Bay Area is one
of my favorite destination
in the United States.
A lot of warmth, a lot of--
like, the sunshine people are
very, very warm, very bright,
very receptive, very hospitable.
And the best part is
that the response here
is always overwhelming.
The last concert, which I did
here about two years back,
was sold out on my arrival.
And this time, also.
In fact, when I arrived
here, I got the news
that the concert tomorrow,
which is happening tomorrow,
is sold out.
And with so much of response,
and so much of demand,
they decided that they want
to do one more concert.
So they've announced a second
concert on the 4th of March.
So that's what Bay Area is.
And I think that's
really wonderful.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I think we
all love to have you here.
And as you said, your
show tomorrow is sold out.
But there is a second
show, so for those of you
who have not bought
the tickets, we'll
give you information about that.
So I wanted to actually get
started with your journey.
PANKAJ UDHAS: I would say
that it's more of a destiny.
It's more of--
I guess, sometimes, you
feel that you are destined,
or you are sent
here to do a job,
or you are sent here to carry
out a particular mission.
When I was growing up, I
grew up in the radio era.
When I was growing up,
when I was a child,
there was no television.
Obviously, there
were no computers,
and there were no
mobile telephones.
And so the only source of
entertainment was radio.
And I think the first
influence during those years
was Begum Akhtar, the
famous ghazal singer,
I used to listen to--
I was quite intrigued because
I was too small to figure out
as to who she was,
what she sang,
but her voice and her style
really appealed to me.
And then slowly,
I inquired and I
got to know that she
was India's pride,
and she was the first lady who
popularized this form of music,
which is ghazal.
And she had peculiar voice.
Her voice was very,
very different
than the normal female
voices, so it really
suited this kind of singing.
And I guess that
impression lasted forever.
And I think that that
was my initiation
into ghazal singing that was--
that's when I got inspired.
And then I started following
this form of music religiously.
And then, obviously, came
the issue of language,
because ghazal, as
you know, basically--
the medium, the
language is Urdu.
And it was, again, a coincidence
that my eldest brother, Manhar
Udhas, was a very
famous playback singer.
Manharji was learning Urdu
from a very, very renowned Urdu
teacher.
Manharji was learning
only because he
was pursuing playback
singing, and he
wanted to really make
his diction very refined,
and he wanted to make sure that
whatever he sang was perfect.
So for that, he
was learning Urdu.
And it was his teacher who
actually really inspired
me, who really, in
fact, impressed me.
And one fine day, with
a lot of hesitation,
I gathered courage to ask him
if he could teach me Urdu.
And he readily agreed.
He said yes.
And let me tell you that
his first reaction was like,
he was aghast, because I was--
SPEAKER: How young
were you at that time?
PANKAJ UDHAS: I'm
talking the BEP era.
So I was like, obviously,
studying in college,
and I was swayed by that ear.
So I had long hair, and I
used to wear bell bottoms.
SPEAKER: I'd love to
see a picture of that.
[LAUGHING]
PANKAJ UDHAS: So he
was like, are you sure
of you want to learn Urdu?
And I said yes.
So he said, fair enough.
And then he started teaching me.
I think that made me
even more determined
that I wanted to pursue this
particular form my music.
And with him, I read a
whole lot of Urdu poets,
starting from what
we call Ustad poets,
poets like [INAUDIBLE],,
and all those stalwarts.
So I think that
really sort of got me
into this entire
ghazal singing form.
And I think this ultimately, I
guess, once I got in the world,
this ultimately
became a passion.
SPEAKER: Yeah, that we
can see in your singing.
PANKAJ UDHAS: And that
passion continues even today.
SPEAKER: Yes, definitely.
So now, let me ask
you how you ventured
from this ghazal singing thing
into the Bollywood industry,
and when did that
happen, and what
was your overall
experience with that?
PANKAJ UDHAS: Well,
as far as cinema,
as far as indie films
are concerned, again,
it's a great story to tell.
It's a great coincidence.
Not very many people
know about it,
but probably I saved it from
my book, which I'm writing now.
And hopefully, I'll release it--
I'll launch my book
by end of this year.
SPEAKER: We would love
to have you again.
Sorry to just say that.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Yeah, sure.
SPEAKER: When you do
your book signing,
we'd would love to have
over and talk about that.
PANKAJ UDHAS: I'll come back
when I'm ready with my book.
Certainly, I'll do that.
So when I was in
college, I still
remember one day-- in
those days, as I said,
we didn't have mobile
telephones and things like that.
So my older brother
came to college,
and he told me that there was
an urgent need for a film song.
There is a wonderful music
composer, a lady composer
called, [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] is a very
famous music director.
She's done music
for many movies.
So she was composing for a
film which had a new star cast.
All the actors in that
film were newcomers.
So they wanted a
different voice.
They wanted a young voice.
And I'm talking
about the era when
we had stalwarts like
[INAUDIBLE],, maestros
like [INAUDIBLE],,
and [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER: I see.
PANKAJ UDHAS: So I
went to the studio,
and I was told that we've
selected you to sing a song.
And I rehearsed the song.
And next day, I
recorded the song.
And this was a film
called "Kamna."
And the film was released
and, obviously, with new star
and with not much to--
not much of a gloss.
The film was not a big
success at the box office.
But the song was released,
and it played on the radio,
and there was a small record.
In those days, there
were no cassettes.
It just a record.
So that's how I started.
And I guess I was
probably 20, 21 years old.
And then somewhere
in my heart, I
knew that I was up against
a huge competition,
because they were
all great maestros,
and I was a newcomer, basically.
However, I tried
and, obviously, I
didn't succeed as a
playback singer in cinema.
So obviously, my heart
was always with ghazals,
and cinema, though it was an
attraction, I wouldn't lie,
but it was never
the first choice.
The first choice
was always ghazals,
and even today, it's ghazals.
And then got to the stage
event, this particular film
was being made.
"Naam" And there was a
situation in the film where
the lead actor, the
protagonist, Sanjay Dutt,
had left the country
and was living abroad.
And there was a
situation that the story
required for him to come back.
So how do you bring him back?
So there were many discussions.
And they were all
legendary people involved
in making of that film.
But Rajendra Kumar,
the famous actor,
was the producer of the film.
And Mahesh Bhatt was
directing the film.
And Salim Khan, who's
part of [INAUDIBLE] team.
And [INAUDIBLE] was writing
the screenplay and story.
[INAUDIBLE],, they
were doing music,
and [INAUDIBLE] she
was writing songs.
So they were all
legendary people involved.
And obviously, everyone
had a different opinion.
So it took them a
while to figure out.
But I guess the storywriter
Salim Khan was very adamant.
He was very sure that
he wanted a real life
singer to portray and to
perform the song in the film.
SPEAKER: Right, right.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Because
he felt that it
should be a singer,
a popular singer, who
should sing this song.
So it looks very authentic.
And so--
SPEAKER: Yeah, I was
going to just share
with people who don't know
what song you're talking about,
which would bring
somebody back home.
Why don't you give
them the name of song?
PANKAJ UDHAS: It is is the
famous "Chithi Aayi Hai."
So after many
discussions and all,
they tried to
figure out as to who
was the popular singer then.
So obviously, they
all discussed,
and they felt that they
needed a young popular singer,
and they all decided
that it was me.
So that's how they picked
me to sing this song,
and they said that they
wanted me to perform
this song in the film as well.
There was a very funny
incident, in fact,
because I still remember that
Rajendra Kumar called me up,
and I had seen him
from my childhood.
And he had those hit films.
And I was a big fan of his.
And especially, Rajendra Kumar
had done a lot of musicals.
He had attended
many movies where
music used to be fantastic.
So I used to love those films.
So when he called me
up, I was like, really
thrilled to receive his call.
And he probably
hadn't realized--
so he, just in
that excitement, he
told me that, Pankaj, you
are acting in my film.
So I was like,
acting in your film?
So he said-- to me I
didn't want to commit
right away, because
when he said acting,
I was a little skeptical.
So I said, can I call you
back and let you know?
So he said, OK.
And then I didn't call
him back because I
was scared to call him
back because I was not
prepared to be an actor.
Because with difficulty,
I had made a name
in the field of singing,
and I said when am I
going to start acting now?
So I held back.
So I didn't return his
call for a couple of days.
He called my eldest
brother Manharji
because they were very friendly.
So he called my brother
and told my brother
that your younger
brother does not
have any decency, because
he's not returned my call.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: You got in trouble.
PANKAJ UDHAS: And so I got
a call from big brother.
He says, you should do this.
You know, because he's such a
senior actor, and how can you--
so I told him I said, there
is no other reason for me
not returning his
call, but I said,
I'm only rather unsure
whether I want to act or not.
SPEAKER: So this was not
a very common thing that
used to happen in those times.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Yes.
SPEAKER: This was the
first time that they
experimented with this.
PANKAJ UDHAS: So he told
told me, in that case,
call him up and tell him
that you don't want to act.
I said, fair enough.
I was shaking.
I called him up.
And I said, sir, sorry I didn't
return your call, because I
got taken aback
because, I said, I'm not
prepared to be an actor.
So he laughed loudly.
And he said, oh god.
He said, no, no, no.
He said, we don't expect
you to be an actor.
But we want you to appear
in the film as Pankaj Udhas,
and we want you to
appear as yourself
and sing the song
so that we can say
that this is Pankaj Udhas
performing in an auditorium.
And that's how the
song came about.
SPEAKER: It was a huge success.
That song was like phenomenal.
It just placed you on
the map of Bollywood.
And so I want you to come
back to the question.
You said you tried, and
then you got this fame--
PANKAJ UDHAS: So
just see the fate
and just see the destiny, that
something where I was probably
refused, rejected, or
not exactly rejected,
but I was, I would say,
overlooked probably.
And suddenly, I find
that all those people
want to jam with me and
wanted me to work for them.
So I guess it's at the end of
the day, I think it's destiny.
SPEAKER: And after "Naam,"
you did many other playbacks.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Oh, yes.
I did.
SPEAKER: Many, many.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Yes, many.
SPEAKER: But then you
continued this journey
towards ghazal
singing and towards--
PANKAJ UDHAS: I always--
my focus was always
ghazal singing,
and I always wanted to--
I guess I've reached
a stage in life
now that, for me,
ghazal singing is not
just a commercial
venture that I pursue.
Or it's not something
which I pursue
for the sake of money or fame.
I think I've reached
a point in life
that I pursue it because I'm
very passionate about it.
I want to spread it
across the world,
so that I want a lot of young
talented singers to dig it up.
Because if you want
this particular genre
to really prosper
and go forward,
then you need a bunch of young
performers, young singers,
to come by and take
it up seriously.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
PANKAJ UDHAS: And for me, it's
more of a mission now in life
than just singing
and performing.
I think I have devoted
nearly 40 years of my life
to this form of music.
And I don't want that
this form of music
should suddenly vanish.
SPEAKER: I agree.
PANKAJ UDHAS: So I
certainly want that,
whatever I can contribute.
SPEAKER: So one thing you said
that when you approached Urdu
teacher, and you said
yourself, [NON-ENGLISH]..
We just don't see that kind of
dedication in ghazal singers
today to focus on diction.
What has changed?
Why is it not that
zeal to do things right
and to do it perfectly?
PANKAJ UDHAS: I
guess what I see--
I'm not talking like an old.
I don't think I'm that old.
But what I see today is that the
level of patience has run out.
And nobody wants to spend years
together to pursue something,
to achieve something.
I guess there is
a sense, there's
a feeling, that you want
to do something very fast.
You want to achieve lots, and
you want to achieve it fast.
And that's where, I think,
even the artists, that's
why the singers do not want
to pursue this form of music.
Because I guess
everyone wants a hit.
Everyone wants that.
You do something, and suddenly,
you become a YouTube sensation.
You have 5 million,
10 million hits.
And so I think ghazal
singing basically calls
for a very serious approach.
And it's very
conservative, and it's
very time-consuming as well.
So I think you really
need to have patience
to pursue this form of
music to be successful.
So, I mean, if any
youngster who wants
to follow or pursue
this form of music,
my advice is that you
got to be very patient.
You got to learn to take
everything in your stride
in terms of success, or if
you are unsuccessful also,
because there is no
guarantee that you can
become an over night sensation.
SPEAKER: Good, good.
So that's a good message
for [INAUDIBLE],, hopefully
some of us.
So you see a lot of
people sitting here.
There are also people
watching you over live stream,
because we allow people who
cannot come to this campus,
allow them to be able to
view the chat elsewhere.
So you brought up YouTube.
I wanted to ask you
a little bit about,
what is your thought
of technology
into the world of music?
We see a lot of your videos, and
ghazals, and albums on YouTube.
How do you feel that it has
helped the music industry?
PANKAJ UDHAS: Well, it's a
great, great platform for--
I would say that for established
singers, it's brilliant.
But I would say,
even for singers
who are struggling singers who
are trying to make it in life,
or singers who are--
YouTube has opened up
a whole new avenue.
Because let's face it--
I'm talking about the
Indian perspective.
I'm not talking about the
international perspective.
But if you look at the
Indian perspective,
as far as India
is concerned, I'm
sure you know about
India as much as I know.
That in India,
there are two things
which are the most popular, I
would say, subjects in India.
One is Bollywood, and
the other is cricket.
I mean, there's nothing which
is as popular as these two
things in India.
So when you talk about
music, India always
was dominated by
Bollywood music.
And not for now, but always.
SPEAKER: Always, yeah.
PANKAJ UDHAS:
YouTube, fortunately,
has opened up a new avenue for a
whole lot of singers who cannot
make it big in Bollywood,
who may not make it big
in Bollywood, or who probably
do not have the means,
or maybe they do not have
an access to Bollywood.
For all those singers, I
think its a great platform.
If they have the talent, it
will get recognized right away.
And there couldn't
be anything which
could be more rewarding than
YouTube, because you know it
instantly.
If your song is
popular on YouTube,
you'll know by the
number of hits.
You know by the number
of views, how many views,
and you'll immediately know that
your song is liked by people.
So I think it's
a great platform.
It's a wonderful platform.
SPEAKER: Good.
Very nice.
Another question I
wanted to ask you
was about the creative process.
Because people who do
playback boxing in Bollywood,
do you go there, somebody
has done the lyrics,
somebody has done the music,
you just go memorize your part.
But ghazal singing and
producing an album, what you do,
figuring out--
share with us something about
that whole creative process.
How do you come up
with the project?
How do you select songs for it?
What is that?
PANKAJ UDHAS: When I
started, I remember
my early years of music.
When you introduced me,
you talked about albums
like "Aahat" and "Mukarrar."
During that period, I
remember that I had an option.
I had a very dear friend.
Unfortunately, he's no more.
He was a poet.
[INAUDIBLE] was his name,
and he was a brilliant poet.
He was kind of a
guide, kind of someone
who guided me regularly as far
as Urdu poetry is concerned.
So we were sitting
one day, and we
were discussing as to how
the Urdu poetry, the content
is relevant to this
generation of listeners.
And we came to a
conclusion then poets
like [INAUDIBLE],, all
brilliant poets, Ustad poets,
as we call them.
But in terms of
for the audiences,
people had limited
access to that Urdu,
which was written somewhere
in the 17th, 18th century.
So we kind of took a
conscious decision that,
why not approach the
poetry in a different way,
so that we can
reach out to larger
audiences across the world.
And the first ghazal we
came across, which qualified
or which suited our purposes,
was Jim [INAUDIBLE]..
Because the poet
was written-- this
was [INAUDIBLE] late
18th century poet.
But he wrote it so simply
that [NON-ENGLISH]..
So very simple to understand,
but wonderful meaning.
Because, as you know, that
in Urdu, when you do it
talk about a couplet, it has
about 20 different layers
of meaning.
It's not just one meaning.
You can uncover so many layers.
And when we tried to
figure out [NON-ENGLISH],,
when you do a
literal translation,
it means that you are talking
with some beautiful person who
is very close to you, and you
are so very fortunate to have
that person.
Then if you open
up layers, then you
realize that the poets, most
of the poets, they was Sufi,
and they had such a major
spiritual approach in life.
So actually, what the poet was
trying to say is that it's God
Almighty, the people who
have that superpower or that
spiritual leader close
to them, [NON-ENGLISH]..
SPEAKER: Right.
PANKAJ UDHAS: So that means
that poetry is unbelievable,
and it's so simple.
But at the same time,
it's so very effective.
So that's when we
started talking
about the creative process.
That's when I started
focusing on poetry, which
would have less of difficult
Persian words, Arabic words,
more of Hindu.
And that's how I got into this
particular creative process.
SPEAKER: And I
think you're right.
What you brought to
the ghazal industry
was an ability to
others to enjoy,
not just somebody who
understands Urdu at that level.
But a common man can also
appreciate it and learn it--
PANKAJ UDHAS: [INAUDIBLE].
And you'll be surprised that the
kind of following which I have
is beyond a
Hindi-speaking audience.
And I think that really
makes me feel wonderful.
I think it's a
great satisfaction.
For example, last month,
I did a concert in a place
called Calicut in Kerala.
And there were 6,000 people.
SPEAKER: Wow.
PANKAJ UDHAS: And
nobody would believe
that 6,000 Keralites would
understand what I'm singing.
But yes, they understand each
and every word of what I sang,
because they have followed
my music, they know my music,
and they know what
exactly I'm singing.
So I think that
it's a great feeling
to reach out to all these areas.
SPEAKER: So continuing with this
thought of creative process,
I think one of the things
we sent out to Googlers
is see if somebody could
suggest some poetry or a couple
of lines, and see how
you fit music to that.
Because like I said, and
reiterating that Bollywood
is very different.
But your creative process
about taking the words,
absorbing the meaning.
So if you wanted to share.
So a couple of Googlers
sent some poetry,
and Pankaj is going to look
at that and then share with us
some of the process
that he goes through
to put music around words.
PANKAJ UDHAS:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Yeah, it's--
SPEAKER: And we are putting
him on the spot a little bit.
[LAUGHING]
PANKAJ UDHAS: I think I'll need
my harmonium to work on this--
SPEAKER: Of course.
But I think in ghazal singing,
music and the feeling of it
is very important equally.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Yes.
How do you express?
Most important is
your expression.
Because they say there is
a very common expression
in most the poets.
They say that
[NON-ENGLISH],, poetry,
they say is [INAUDIBLE].
Poetry is not something
which you can transfer it.
SPEAKER: True.
PANKAJ UDHAS: It's
something which you feel.
If you don't feel it,
then it's not right.
So you've got to feel the words,
you've got to feel the poetry.
And that's what the
words are all about.
SPEAKER: Yes.
PANKAJ UDHAS: I'll try.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: OK.
Sure.
[PLAYING HARMONIUM]
PANKAJ UDHAS: These
are the words, which
I'm seeing for the first time.
[INAUDIBLE] Yeah,
I'll try to sing them.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
SPEAKER: So you guys
may not realize this,
but we just took a print-out
of this poem written
by one of the Googlers, and
handed it to Pankaj and said,
can you use this to compose?
Very, very impressive.
That's beautiful.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Now that he has
the harmonium in front,
I was going ask him to sing
the very famous song we
were talking about,
"Chithi Aayi Hai."
However, I want to
request the audience, that
doesn't mean you
guys get up and leave
for India because [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHING]
Which is what happened
in the movies.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Yeah, but I
must share this with you,
not to inspire
you, anyone of you,
because I'm sure that you all
are doing very well in life.
And I remember--
[LAUGHING]
The reason why I use the word
inspire, because I remember I
was doing a concert
in Jaipur, and there
was this gentleman who came
to see me after the concert
and gave me a book.
And he opened the front
cover, and inside, he
had written "Dedicated
to Pankaj Udhas."
So I said, thank you very
much for the dedication.
And he said, no, the reason why
he had dedicated the book to me
was that he was here
in Silicon Valley,
and he was a software engineer.
And he said he was doing
very well, extremely well.
And I'm talking about when
"Chithi Aayi Hai" was--
the film was released
in the late '80s.
So he said he heard the song.
And then he said he kept
on listening to the song.
And he said, one fine day,
he just packed his bags
and came back to India.
SPEAKER: Wow.
PANKAJ UDHAS: And he said,
when he came back to India,
he didn't know what he
would do with his life
because here, he had a
fantastic job and whatever.
So he said he tried his
luck with a startup,
start his own venture.
And fortunately, he did
extremely well, better
than what he was doing here.
So he said that inspired him to
write the book about his life,
and he dedicated the book to me.
But that doesn't
mean that you all
leave and come back to India.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Next thing you
know, these guys are all
booking flights
[MUSIC - PANKAJ UDHAS, "CHITHI
AAYI HAI"]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
PANKAJ UDHAS: Thank you.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] I have
heard this song so many times.
Still, [NON-ENGLISH],,
I get goosebumps,
and it brings tears to my eyes.
Beautiful.
Beautiful song.
Changing gears a
little bit, I wanted
to talk a little bit
about the nonprofits
that you're involved in.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Yes.
SPEAKER: And if you wanted to
share a little bit about that.
And [INAUDIBLE]
PANKAJ UDHAS: I guess so
during my growing up days
and during the process, I always
felt that we, as human beings,
could do so much for so
many people who are probably
less privileged, or maybe
people who need support,
people who need help.
And I always felt that
when God has given you
something very
special, like a talent,
you can share that
talent to help somebody.
Because you probably,
you were a chosen one.
And that means that your
responsibility becomes doubled,
because that means that you
are required to do something
extra, something more.
And I don't know, but
all along my life,
I didn't like the word
charity, because I always
felt that that is
nothing like charity.
I feel that what you do
is your duty as a human,
as a human being.
That you do something for
your fellow human being.
You are not obliging him,
or you're not doing charity.
What you're doing is you're
trying to help somebody.
And I grew up with this
attitude in my life.
And I still remember that I
was doing a concert in Mumbai
for a fundraiser, for children
who have this genetical blood
disorder called thalassemia.
And at that point,
I had no clue.
I had no idea as to what
thalassemia was all about.
So I was invited to visit the
center where they were treating
thalassemic children in Mumbai.
And I went to visit the center.
And I was taken around.
And when I saw those children,
and when I saw their plight,
I felt that there is
something like being deprived
that is something like
being unfortunate,
especially in those children.
Because this is such a dreaded
blood disorder, that the child
needs a blood transfusion
every three weeks.
The child needs to take
one injection every day,
which is given through a pump.
The pump is tied to the stomach
for eight hours every day.
It's a whole process,
where you feel
that what has the child
done to go to all this?
I was so moved, so I
joined that organization,
and I told them, I said,
I'll work with you.
And I started working with them.
It's nearly 30 years now that
I've been working for them.
The, I wouldn't say
consolation, but I
would say the only bright
part, or the only good part
about this whole
process is that when
I joined the whole
organization, there
was no cure for thalassemia.
Today, there is bone
marrow transplant,
which can cure the
child of thalassemia,
and the child leads
a normal life.
So what I have done is
that we have been focused
on bone marrow transplant.
In the last three years, we
got more than 50 children
bone marrow transplant
done in India.
And today, those 50 children
jumping, running around.
They have no thalassemia.
[APPLAUSE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER: Wow.
Wow.
PANKAJ UDHAS: He says
[INAUDIBLE] you don't
need to [INAUDIBLE] cover.
You don't need to do anything.
I mean, he says, you
look at this child,
and you see his smiling face,
and that's God right there.
SPEAKER: That's true.
PANKAJ UDHAS:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
If you're privileged,
if you are blessed,
then I think it's
our duty to share it
with a whole lot of
people who need it.
SPEAKER: That's such a
noble thought, Pankaj.
I wish more and more
celebrities and people
who have achieved what you
have thought like that.
I think the world could
be such a different place.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Oh, yes.
Certain.
SPEAKER: So I'm very thankful
to you for doing that along.
So a lot of people
might not know this,
but along with being
such an amazing artist,
you're also such an
amazing human being.
So please continue
to do that, and we
would love to spread that
information through our teams
and make sure that you get
more and more support on that.
PANKAJ UDHAS: And thalassemia
is nothing but awareness.
Because it's a genetically
inherited blood disorder.
So if there is awareness, then
you can stop it, for sure.
SPEAKER: Sure, sure.
Thank you very much
for sharing that.
Now I wanted to
also ask you like,
what are the recent projects?
If you can share
about whatever you're
working on, if it's
not a super secret.
PANKAJ UDHAS: Well, there
is kind of a secrecy.
SPEAKER: I thought I as much.
PANKAJ UDHAS: But I'm
working on a new project.
As soon as I finish
the North American
tour, when I go back to India,
I start working on that project.
It's a project which involves
another legendary artist whom
I'm collaborating with.
And we're working on
a project which should
be one of its kind, hopefully.
And next time when
I'm here at Google,
I'll probably bring the
CD and share it with you.
SPEAKER: Oh, perfect.
That would be very nice.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So first of all, why are there
so many ghazals around alcohol?
[LAUGHING]
PANKAJ UDHAS: Yesterday Sonny
asked me the same question.
SPEAKER: Oh, really?
PANKAJ UDHAS: On the radio.
Yeah.
But [NON-ENGLISH].
This is not my
fault. [NON-ENGLISH]..
SPEAKER: [NON-ENGLISH]
PANKAJ UDHAS: Because
what has happened
is that all these numbers
which you mentioned,
they were not
recorded in one day.
That were not
recorded in one album.
These numbers happened
over a period of 30 years.
SPEAKER: I see.
PANKAJ UDHAS: But because you
want to enjoy these songs,
and because you want to have
your drink, so you compiled
all these songs, you
have your playlist.
And you say, OK, Pankaj Udhas,
[NON-ENGLISH],, Pankaj Udhas,
[NON-ENGLISH],, Pankaj
Udhas, [NON-ENGLISH]..
But it's not my fault. I have
never propagated this subject.
I've been, in fact,
in India, I've
been approached to
endorse these brands.
I've been approached
to endorse tobacco.
I've been approached to
endorse [INAUDIBLE] masala.
But I have taken
a policy decision
that I would never ever
endorse any of these brands,
because I don't want to
encourage this stuff.
So--
SPEAKER: See, again,
this is a sign
that you are thinking
about things rather
than just being an artist.
Because I see a lot of popular
Bollywood stars who don't--
PANKAJ UDHAS:
[INAUDIBLE] alcohol, yes.
SPEAKER: Anything.
Anything, [INAUDIBLE].
Whatever.
Whatever we feel that we don't
want our kids to be exposed to.
They're endorsing
all those items, So.
We appreciate artists
like yourself--
PANKAJ UDHAS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: --who put
some thought into it,
rather than just [INAUDIBLE].
Yes, thank you.
So why not one
ghazal on that topic?
PANKAJ UDHAS: No, but I
will instead of saying--
someone was asking me so.
The rest, you can come for the
concert and listen, for sure.
But I will [NON-ENGLISH].
[MUSIC - PANKAJ UDHAS]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
PANKAJ UDHAS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Such a beautiful song.